[موسيقى]
هذه الطائره التي طورتها شركه
البريطانيه لتكون مقاتله وقذفت قنابل
متوسطه اعتمدت في تصميمها على شكل جديد في
هذا الوقت حيث تم تصميم جناحين اسفل
مقصوره القياده في المقدمه
بالكامل من الخشب عدم استخدام اي معدن في
هيكل طائره
سلاح الجو البريطانيا لكن هذا الامر مكان
الطائره التي تم تزويدها بمحرك من تصنيع
شركه رولز رويس من ان تحلق بسرعه 640 كيلو
مترا في الساعه لتصبح حينها واحده من اسرع
طائرات جيلها بل ونبدا قويا للمقاتلات
الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
لكن وبعد تزويدها بمنظومه اوبو الحديثه
للملاحه وتحديد الاهداف في عام 1942
الى اول قاذفه قنابل ليليه حيث كانت تنفذ
مهام اما ضمن سرب من ذات طراز واما تقود
القاذفات الكبيره للعمل كدليل الى مكان
الهاتف
لتتبع اثر الرادار الذي كانت تستخدمه
الطائرات الالمانيه هذا الامر مكنها من
اعتراض القاذفات والمقاتلات الالمانيه
ليلا واسقاقاتها
في اسقاط 470 طائره من الطائرات الحربيه
الالمانيه في هذا الوقت
[موسيقى]